.
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US ON A
FRIDAY NIGHT.
MEN WHO HIDE, THAT'S THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M STARTING TONIGHT WITH A FEW
HYPOTHETICALS.
BACK TO LAW SCHOOL DAYS.
SO IF YOU'RE THINKING OF PUTTING
AN ADDITION ON YOUR HOUSE, MAYBE
RENOVATING YOUR KITCHEN, WOULD
YOU TRUST JOHN FETTERMAN TO
REVIEW THE BIDS AND NEGOTIATE
WITH THE BUILDERS?
FOR THAT MATTER, WOULD YOU TRUST
JOE BIDEN TO HIRE THE BEST TEAM
TO GET THE JOB DONE?
NOW, IF THE ANSWER TO THOSE
QUESTIONS IS NO AND I IMAGINE IT
IS FOR MOST OF USE, NEITHER MAN
IS REALLY CAPABLE OF SERVING AS
A U.S. SENATOR OR THE U.S.
PRESIDENT.
AT LEAST NOT WITHOUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE MAKING DECISIONS FOR HIM,
PROTECTING HIM FROM SCRUTINY AND
HIDING THE TRUTH FROM THE
VOTERS.
OF COURSE, THIS IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN BOTH CASES.
NOW, NBC NEWS REPORTER DASHA
BURNS DARED TO PROVIDE FACTS
THAT HELPED PENNSYLVANIA VOTERS
ANSWER THE QUESTION ON THEIR
MIND.
NAMELY IS FETTERMAN REALLY WELL
ENOUGH TO TAKE ON THE DEMANDS OF
THE JOB OF U.S. SENATOR.
>> BECAUSE OF HIS STROKE, HE
REQUIRED CLOSED CAPTIONING TO
READ OUR QUESTIONS AS WE ASKED
THEM.
LASTER, IN SMALL TALK BEFORE THE
INTERVIEW WITHOUT CAPTIONING, IT
WASN'T CLEAR HE WAS
UNDERSTANDING OUR CONVERSATION.
>> MIND YOU, THIS WAS THE FIRST
SIT-DOWN INTERVIEW THAT
FETTERMAN HAD AGREED TO SINCE
HIS STROKE.
SO PRETTY IMPORTANT, DON'T YOU
THINK, TO BE TRANSPARENT WITH
THE VOTERS, CORRECT?
AND THE IMMEDIATE REACT OF THE
PRESS POODLES TO THAT REPORTER'S
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT SHE SAW IS TO
ATTACK THEIR OWN REPORTER.
>> OTHER JOURNALISTS THAT DEALT
WITH FETTERMAN CAME FORWARD AND
SAY THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE.
>> OUR TEAM WAS THE FIRST TO BE
IN THE ROOM WITH FETTERMAN FOR
AN INTERVIEW RATHER THAN VIA
REMOTE VIDEO CONFERENCE.
OUR CREW DID FIND THAT SMALL
TALK BEFORE THAT CAPTIONING WAS
DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF THOSE
AUDITORY PROCESSING ISSUES.
>> Laura: SAVANNAH, SAVANNAH.
LEFT WING WEBSITES JOINED IN TO
PROMOTE THE ABSURD ON ITS FACE
CLAIM THAT THAT REPORTER WAS
SOMEHOW FUELLING BIAS AGAINST
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES OR AS
ITS CALLED ABLISM.
NOW, FROM THE OUTSET, THE ANGLE
HAS EXPRESSED EMPATHY AND
SYMPATHY FOR FETTERMAN'S
CONDITION.
WE REPEATEDLY URGED HIM TO TAKE
THE TIME AT HOME TO HEAL AND
RECOVER.
A STROKE IS SERIOUS.
IT'S LIFE THREATENING AND A
MAJOR MEDICAL EVENT.
RECOVERY CAN BE LONG AND
ARDUOUS.
AND OUTCOMES VARY.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS.
YET NOW THE LEFT IS SO DESPERATE
TO HOLD ON TO POWER, ITS EVEN
ENLISTING WIVES TO HELP HIDE THE
POLITICIANS TRUE PHYSICAL AND
COGNITIVE STRUGGLES.
STANDING BY YOUR MAN IS ONE
THING BUT PROPPING HIM UP WHEN
PEOPLE NEED STRONG AND VIGOROUS
LEADERSHIP, THAT'S DISHONEST AND
CRAVEN.
ENTER GISELE FETTERMAN.
>> WHAT A DISSERVICE SHE DID TO
MY HUSBAND AND ANYONE FACING A
DISABILITY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THERE WERE NOT
CONSEQUENCES, RIGHT?
THERE'S CONSEQUENCES FOR FOLKS
IN THESE POSITIONS THAT ARE ANY
OF THE ISMS.
SHE WAS LIKE WHERE IS YOUR
TRAINING.
IT WAS A PAULING TO SEE.
I HAVEN'T HEARD AN APOLOGY.
IT HASN'T COME.
>> Laura: IT WAS APPALLING TO
SEE?
WHAT EXACTLY WAS APPALLING?
THE REPORTER IS POINTING OUT
THAT THE INTERVIEW IS UNUSUAL.
IT WAS UNUSUAL.
THAT A CANDIDATE FOR SENATE
REQUIRES A GIANT SCREEN IN FRONT
OF HIM TO ANSWER FAIRLY SIMPLE
QUESTIONS?
LOOK, AS MANY OF US KNOW FIRST
HAND, BEING EVEN A PART-TIME
CARE GIVER TO A SICK FAMILY
MEMBER ITSELF IS VERY DIFFICULT,
VERY TRYING.
BUT THIS DOESN'T GIVE ANYONE ANY
SPOUSE THE RIGHT TO TRASH A
REPORTER FOR ACTUALLY DOING HER
JOB.
THEY CERTAINLY WERE ALL ABOUT
PROTECTING THE PRESS WHEN TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP DEMONIZES THE
PRESS.
>> HE CALLS THE PRESS THE ENEMY
OF THE PEOPLE.
THESE RECKLESS WORDS HAVE
CONSEQUENCE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> IT'S A DANGEROUS ENVIRONMENT.
>> Laura: INDEED LAST MONTH,
THINGS GOT DEADLY WHEN ONE
DEMOCRAT GOT AMPED UP ABOUT
SUPPOSEDLY NEGATIVE REPORTING.
>> POLICE HAVE CONFIRMED THE
SEARCH WARRANT IS IN CONNECTION
WITH THE MURDER OF 69-YEAR-OLD
JEFF GHERMAN.
ROBERT TELLES WAS THE REPORT OF
AN INVESTIGATION OF BULLYING,
FAVORITISM AND HAVING AN AFFAIR
WITH A WOMAN IN HIS OFFICE.
TELLES LOST HIS PRIMARY AND MANY
BLAME THE NEGATIVE REPORTS.
>> Laura: IT'S VERY DISTURBING.
OF COURSE, THIS DOESN'T FIT THE
DEMOCRAT NARRATIVE.
THE DEMOCRAT IN THIS CASE IS THE
ACCUSED KILLER.
IT'S NOT JUST GISELE FETTERMAN'S
VENDETTA AGAINST A REPORTER, IT
SEEMS LIKE SHE'S THE CANDIDATE.
AGAIN, WE'RE VICTIMS, SO VOTE
FOR US.
>> WHAT HAS IT BEEN LIKE
CAMPAIGNING AT A TIME IN WHICH
THERE'S THIS UNPRECEDENTED WAVE
OF NEGATIVE ADS, B.S. ATTACKS?
>> I'M GOOD.
I CRY A LOT.
BUT EVERYTHING IS FINE.
I TEACH MY KIDS TO BE GOOD
PEOPLE, RIGHT?
THEN YOU HAVE LIKE AN AWFUL
PERSON RUNNING TO REPRESENT
THEMSELVE
THEMSELVES.
PEOPLE THOUGHT LIKE WITH TRUMP
THIS CAN'T HAPPEN.
IT CAN HAPPEN.
>> Laura: THIS TEMPLATE FOR THIS
WIFE SHIELD HUSBAND ROUTINE IS
ALWAYS PLAYING OUT BEFORE OUR
EYES A TRACTOR TRAILER WHITE
HOUSE ALMOST EVERY DAY.
>> SPREAD THE FAITH, FOLKS.
THANKS SO VERY, VERY MUCH.
THANKS.
>> GOD BLESS AMERICA.
THANK YOU.
>> Laura:
>> WHO IS REALLY IN CHARGE HERE?
DO WE EVEN KNOW?
DOES ANYONE REALLY THINK THAT
JOE BIDEN IS CAPABLE OF WORKING
12 HOUR DAYS IF NEEDED?
THE MEAGER REPORTING ON HIS
WORKDAYS SEEMS TO INDICATE THAT
HE'S GOOD FOR MAYBE FOUR OR FIVE
HOURS.
OF COURSE, EVERYONE KNOWS THAT
BEING LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD
REQUIRES ROUND-THE-CLOCK FOCUS
AND STAMINA.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO PRETEND THAT
JOE IS CAPABLE OF THIS?
THAT HE'S REALLY RUNNING THE
SHOW?
>> THEY DON'T CALL IT SUPER
TUESDAY FOR NOTHING.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS MY LITTLE
SISTER, VALERIE.
I'M JILL'S HUSBAND.
OH, NO.
YOU SWITCHED ON ME.
THIS IS MY WIFE.
THIS IS MY SISTER.
THEY SWITCHED ON ME.
>> Laura: NOW, REMEMBER, THAT
WAS TWO YEARS AGO.
HE'S GONE FROM NOT REMEMBERING
HIS WIFE OR HIS SISTER TO NOT
REMEMBERING HOW TO EXIT A STAGE
WHEN HIS WIFE IS NOT THERE TO
DIRECT HIM.
>> THANK YOU ALL FOR ALL YOU'RE
DOING.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU.
AT THE END OF SUCH A MOMENTOUS
EVENT, THE WORD THANK YOU SEEMS
INADEQUATE.
>> Laura: THAT STILL TERRIFIES
ME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK PUTIN AND XI
THINK OR ARE WE GUILTY OF AGEISM
FOR RACING THE OBVIOUS QUESTIONS
HERE.
THIS IS NOT GETTING BETTER.
IT'S GETTING WORSE.
SHOULD WE ASSUME THE FIRST LADY
WILL BE THERE CORRECTING THE
PRESIDENT IN MEETINGS WITH WORLD
LEADERS SINCE SHE HAS TO DO IT
ON A ROUTINE BASIS?
>> A LITTLE CHANGE IN THE A
RANGEMENT OF WHO IS ON STAGE
BECAUSE OF THE FIRST LADY'S
HUSBAND CONTRACTING COVID.
LOOK AT THIS ROOM.
WHAT YOU'LL SEE -- PARDON?
THAT'S RIGHT.
SHE'S FINE.
[LAUGHTER]
SECOND LADY, THE FIRST
GENTLEMAN.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> Laura: IF ONLY IT WERE FUNNY.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
FOR MEN IN POSITIONS OF POWER TO
HIDE BEHIND THEIR WIVES.
TO HIDE BEHIND PHONY VICTIM
STATUS.
IT'S EQUALLY DISGRACEFUL FOR THE
WIVES AND THE STAFF TO STONE
WALL AND DEFAME THOSE ASKING
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS.
IF THE CANDIDATE CAN'T SUBMIT TO
REAL QUESTIONS OR NEEDS A FAMILY
MEMBER OR A JOURNALIST TO PLAY
DEFENSE FOR HIM, THEN HE DOESN'T
DESERVE YOUR VOTE OR SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION.
GIVEN WHAT WE'RE ALL FACING HERE
IN AMERICA AND